to a conversation
about antiviral agents.
In this case, we'll
be talking about the
drugs that are used
for the treatment of
****** infection. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
Please contact
me if you'd like
to have a chat
about pharmacology.
Here are our learning
objectives, the
usual things that
you expect that every
student and physician
should know about,
the relevant
pharmacokinetic properties,
mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms,
therapeutic uses,
adverse effects,
and how we can
manage them,
and drug interactions.
Here are our
preparation materials.
videos are only
if you wish to
use them certainly
do use the
practice questions
I do require that
links and key
points to help
you put everything
into the
what do I need
to know category
let's begin.
The ****** virus is
a large DNA virus.
It has a large
genome because it is
frequently in non
-dividing cells, so it
needs to supply some
of its own enzymes
for replication. And
we'll take a closer
look at that. This
is an important
idea because of how
our nucleoside analogs
are activated. So
we'll get to that.
Just a brief
overview of the
replication of the
****** viridae.
They enter the cell
as all viruses do.
They have some initial
activity here using
proteins that come
packaged up in the
virus package, moves
into the nucleus,
does its replication,
gets packaged through
the endoplasmic
reticulum and
transported to
the cell membrane
and exocytosed.
Now HSV, ******
simplex virus,
migrates to the cell
body of the neuron
and it becomes
latent in the in the
ganglia and it can
be reactivated.
Cytomegalovirus
latency is established
in the hematopoietic
progenitor cells.
So these we do not
cure these viral
infections. They do
become latent. We
can suppress them
sometimes and we can
treat them which
will only reduce the
time at which the
infection is evident.
These are the classes
of the antiviral
agents and this
is the group that
we're going to
be talking about.
We'll begin with
this overview. We
have drugs for the
treatment of ******
simplex and varicella
zoster virus.
So this is all one
group to treat these
two different types
of ****** viridae.
And we have our drugs
for the treatment of
cytomegalovirus. You
can see it's quite a few
of them. One, two,
three, four, five, six.
I did put STARS on
all of them for two
reasons the mechanisms
are interesting and
mechanistically important
for your pharmacology
understanding of these
drugs and the viruses
viral targets of
these drugs and also
because they're all
used in practice and
you're likely to see them
certainly most or all
of them can show up
on a board exam. And
then we have some that
are used topically.
Plast effects. Well, the
root of administration
depends on the drug
and the clinical
use. If a drug can be
used topically and be
fully effective, that
would be great because
then we're not
exposing the patient to
systemic drug levels.
But most often they have
to be taken for systemic
drug levels. ******
is certainly ideal and
we have many drugs.
Many of the drugs
listed can be given
****** and some are
only given parenterally.
Most have poor
bioavailability. So pro
-drugs have been developed
that improve the
bioavailability of
the active component.
The poor bioavailability
decreases
with the increasing
dose because
of saturable
absorptive processes.
Excuse me.
I pushed the
wrong button.
The drugs are
widely distributed
in the body
fluids, including
the cerebral
spinal fluid.
this is what I'm
talking about with
them being pro-drugs
they are actually
turned into
triphosphates and I'll go
through this when we
get to the mechanisms
and it is the
triphosphates that are
within the cells that
are the active drugs
Now, so let's say
acyclovir itself
is a prodrug
because it has to be
acyclovir triphosphate.
And that said,
valacyclovir is a
prodrug of acyclovir,
which then goes on to
be triphosphorylated.
Do you understand
what I'm saying?
Famcyclovir is a prodrug
of pencyclovir. Now,
acyclovir is given,
usually IV, it can be
given ****** too, and
pencyclovir, however,
is not given that
way. Only famcyclovir
will produce the systemic
pencyclovir levels.
Renal excretion
of unchanged drug.
So bells should be
ringing in your brain.
renal excretion of
unchanged drug we
better be alert to
renal dosing patients
who have reduced
renal function and
how does it get into
the nephron both by
glomerular filtration
these are pretty
small molecules that
are dissolved in
the serum and also
by active secretion.
Half-life, well that's
just really going
to vary according to
the specific drug.
But we also have to
think of the biologic
half-life because they
accumulate inside the
cell. So the biologic
half-life can be
different than the
plasma half-life, longer.
So we'll begin
with acyclovir,
valicyclovir,
and famcyclovir.
Acyclovir is the
prototype, the first
one to be developed
in this group.
These are all guanosine
analogs and I put
guanosine here so you can
understand what we're
talking about and
if you use your
imagination you can see the
resemblance to guanosine
and remember this
is going to be
resembling in three
-dimensional space this
is just a flat picture.
The acyclovir does not
have a three-prime,
this would be a three
-prime hydroxyl group.
This is going to
become important
when we talk about
the mechanism.
Pencyclovir, on the
other hand, does have
a three-prime, I'm
thinking this is the
three-prime spot, hydroxyl
group, retains the
three-prime group,
and we'll see how that
is relevant when we
get to the mechanism.
Here's valacyclovir.
It's got this
little bit on here,
this valine, val,
valine, or valacyclovir,
and this comes
off quickly to
release the acyclovir.
FAM-cyclovir, that's
the same idea,
and quickly turns
into pencyclovir.
Pharmacokinetics first,
they're all oral,
but acyclovir is
also IV, and acyclovir
is also topical.
The bioavailability
of acyclovir oral
is pretty low, as
you can see, dose
-dependent. The greater
the dose, the lower
the bioavailability.
10% is pretty low.
Compare this to
acyclovir, where
the bioavailability
of the
actual acyclovir
is much higher.
Famcyclovir produces
a bioavailability of
its active pencyclovir
of 75%. So it makes
a lot of sense to
figure out why they
developed these pro
-drugs in the first place.
Because we get much
better systemic levels.
Widely distributed,
including the CSF.
This is class
effect, class effect.
Renal excretion,
class effect.
The plasma half
-life is fairly
short with acyclovir.
And, in fact,
it often needs to be
given five times a day.
Famcyclovir, on
the other hand,
has a bit longer
half-life.
Mechanism. Now, I
mentioned that ******
viruses are large
viruses, and they come
ready with their own
replication machinery.
So,
acyclovir,
pencyclovir are
activated by viral
thymidine kinase.
So if the drug enters
a cell that is not
infected with virus,
which of course it will,
then it will not
be activated. That
viral thymidine
kinase has to be
present in order to
activate the drug
to the first step
in the activation
process, which is
the monophosphate.
And then the host
kinases take over, put
on two more phosphates,
and we get our active
acyclovir or pencyclovir
triphosphate.
And this accumulates
in the infected cells,
as I said, but not
the infected cells.
So how do they
work? Let's
look at acyclovir first.
Competitive
inhibition of viral
DNA polymerase and
chain termination.
So how is this happening?
Well acyclovir
triphosphate competes with
deoxyguanosine
triphosphate for the
viral DNA polymerase
and that will
therefore inhibit
DNA synthesis.
Additionally, because
it does not have that 3'
hydroxyl group, it
gets incorporated
into the viral DNA,
forms an irreversible
complex because
this would be the
point at which the
chain would continue.
Chain goes on down
the line, but it can't
because that hydroxyl
group is missing.
So that causes obligate
chain termination.
So acyclovir triphosphate,
those two mechanistic
processes of
inhibiting viral DNA
polymerase and causing
obligate chain termination
as it's incorporated
into the viral DNA.
And that just stops the
chain elongation process.
Now, pencyclovir,
it's going
to be this part
right here.
Pencyclovir does have
that 3' hydroxyl group.
It also causes the
competitive inhibition
of DNA polymerase,
but it does not
cause this obligate
chain termination.
The DNA synthesis will
stop on down the line.
Efficacy.
Well,
in a word,
essentially the same.
Okay, three words.
Acyclovir triphosphate
is effective
in the treatment
of HSV-1, HSV
-2, and varicella
zoster virus.
Varicella zoster would
be chicken pox, chicken
pox, it's hard to
write on this screen,
and something called
zoster, which
is shingles.
The difference here
is that when treating
varicella infection,
varicella zoster
infection, a higher dose
is required because the
drug acycloviris is
less potent against
varicella zoster than
it is against ******
simplex, but giving the
higher dose is really
no problem. The drug
is quite tolerable.
It does have some other
activity, but it's
weaker, and I'm not
asking you to remember
this part. It's just
one of those things
you might want to just
keep under your hat.
Because of the
weaker activity it is
not used for the
treatment of infections
caused by those
****** viruses.
Looking at
famcyclovir now and of
course it's
the pencyclovir
triphosphate that
we're talking about.
about the same
****** infections.
It does have a lower
affinity for viral
DNA polymerase than
does acyclovir, however
this is offset because
it achieves a higher
intracellular
concentration than does
the acyclovir triphosphate.
So as a result,
famcyclovir, since
pencyclovir is
not available
for systemic use,
acyclovir, and of
course valacyclovir,
essentially have
similar efficacy.
Just a little
reiteration here about
selectivity. Viral kinase
initiates activation
of the drug. High
concentrations in virus
-infected cells, but
not uninfected cells.
And the drug
triphosphate affinity
for viral DNA
polymerase is higher
than for host
DNA polymerase.
Hence,
selectivity and relative
safety. Relative safety.
So, selectivity
again, it's about the
target, the drug
target, viral target,
and about the
safety of the host.
So, what is the
target? DNA polymerase.
What about host
DNA polymerase?
It has much
less affinity.
That's how we can
think about it.
Well, resistance.
Resistance, resistance.
Whenever we're
talking about any kind
of anti-infective,
we're talking about
resistance potential.
Fortunately, it's rare in
the immunocompetent host.
The immunocompetent
host has an immune
system to help, but
some resistance has been
reported in the
immunocompromised host.
Fortunately,
it's not a great
percentage, but we
need to be vigilant.
So how does this
happen? Well,
it's very simple.
Point mutations,
base insertions
or deletions in
the genes, and
that will change
their affinity
for the drug.
Mutations in the UL23
gene, which is the
viral thymidine,
it codes the viral
thymidine kinase. Why is
that important? Because
it is the viral
thymidine kinase that
phosphorylates
that first step,
forming the
monophosphate.
And if that
doesn't happen,
then the drug is
not activated.
Altered thymidine kinase
substrate specificity.
So what does this mean?
The thymidine gets
phosphorylated.
Therefore,
replication can occur.
but it does not
activate acyclovir.
Altered DNA
polymerase is really,
really rare. I'm
just mentioning it
because there are
reports of it.
Cross-resistant, simidine
kinase deficient.
That would be number one.
acyclovir resistant
hsv and what's the
cross resistance well
we need that thymidine
kinase for acyclovir
valley cyclovir
famcyclovir and gancyclovir
for the treatment
of hsb we'll get to
gancyclovir later
mint goals of therapy
if initiated early in
that prodromal stage
when the person just
starts to feel it
coming on. The drug may
reduce the duration of
the lesion and the acute
pain and shorten
healing time. All good.
Importantly, it also
reduces the period of
viral shedding which
reduces transmission.
So those two
benefits, reduced
pain, shortened
healing time,
and reduced
viral shedding
reduces transmission.
With varicella zoster
virus, reduce acute
neuralgia and post
-herpetic neuralgia.
The varicella
virus zoster
shingles causes
that neuralgia.
But recurrences are
common after the
therapy is stopped and
in certain patients
there may be a need
for suppression.
In other words,
taking the dose,
usually a lower dose,
for a long time.
******* ******, really
what I said before.
Recurrent *******
******, pretty much
what I said
before. Cold sores,
this is called ******
labialis. Again,
same thing. So,
all these basic
pharmacologic
principles apply here.
So, by looking at
the big picture
and fitting everything
into the big
picture, it's easier
to learn one big
thing that everything
applies to.
And then just learn the
few drug-specific
features.
Chicken pox and shingles.
Early treatment
reduces the total
number of lesions,
duration of symptoms,
viral shedding,
and post-herpetic
neuralgia. Just
what we said before.
Pretty quick onset
within a day.
Zoster within three days.
And here's our
practice point.
The zoster, the
varicella zoster
virus treatments
require higher doses.
because VZV is
less susceptible to
the drugs than is
****** simplex.
Basic point, you need
more drug molecules
around in order
to be effective
against the varicella
virus, zoster virus.
What about populations?
Well, the new babies
can be born with those
infections. we can
give intravenous
acyclovir and what are
the outcomes always
ask yourself if i'm
going to do this how is
it going to help what
is going to be the
outcome early therapy
can prevent mortality
and complications
that's a very important
outcome hsv viral
encephalitis varicella
pneumonia ******
zoster infection and
immunocompromised
hosts, all acyclovir IV.
And prophylaxis
now, prevention of
CMV, cytomegalovirus
infection with
high doses of acyclovir
or valacyclovir.
Now notice this
is not treatment,
not treatment.
Acyclovir and
famcyclovir have weaker
activity against
CMV. So it's not for
treatment, but it'll
still be useful for
prevention of
CMV infection in
individuals who are
receiving stem cell
transplant, allogeneic
hematopoietic cell
transplant, or solid
organ transplant.
Now, I mentioned it, but
ganciclovir,
valgancyclovir, these
are really
preferred adverse
effects well fortunately
they're really
well tolerated by and
large maybe a little
nausea maybe some vomiting
and certain people
who are really
sensitive to that sort
of thing potentially
diarrhea rash headache
but these are really
infrequent now we
still have to be thinking
about the important
potential serious
toxicities so that We
can be alert. We can
be ready to mitigate
them to reduce their
potential severity.
So acute kidney injury.
Acyclovir can form
crystals, and those
crystals can form
obstructions and nephropathy.
They can also get
into the interstitial
tissues and cause
an inflammation.
that's the immune
reaction and we're
calling that
nephritis interstitial
nephritis and renal
tubular necrosis due
to the direct cytotoxicity
of an acyclovir
metabolite very
rare when would we
see these things
high doses high doses
especially high
durations high doses
intravenous we're
putting drug right
into the vein and
it's achieving high
concentrations high
peaks very quickly
so how can we mitigate
that well we put the
drug in slowly slowly
slowly drip drip drip
so it doesn't cause
those very high peaks
practice point maintain
adequate hydration
and by doing so that
can reduce the potential
for this crystal
formation that can
occur with these high
doses neurotoxicity
fortunately rare again
dose dependent again
more likely with the
intravenous acyclovir
or of course very high
dose valley cyclovir
so what would we see
Confusion, agitation,
hallucinations,
impaired consciousness,
and even more rarely,
some motor signs.
Aphasia, ataxia,
tremor, myoclonus,
and then leading
to seizures.
And finally, with
valacyclovir,
this is a drug
-specific effect
that you can
keep in mind.
very high doses and
we're talking about
suppressive therapy
in patients with AIDS
because this is going
to be high doses
over long periods
what has been
seen is thrombotic
microangiopathy. So,
what this means is
clots forming in
the small vessels.
That can lead to
thrombocytopenic
purpura, hemolytic uremic
syndrome, as the
small vessels get
clogged, get obstructed
by these thrombi.
Valacyclovir,
high doses, as are
needed in patients
with severe
immunosuppression
as AIDS patients.
Well, can we use
them in pregnancy?
Well, yes, for
the treatment of
varicella in the
pregnant individual.
treatment of *******
****** and suppressive
therapy beginning
36 weeks gestation
so this is the point
uh just a few weeks
before term when the
baby is due to be
born and that's going
to prevent vertical
infection vertical
transmission well can
the baby nurse if the
mother is taking the
these antivirals yes
because really very
little of it gets
into the breast milk
can children take it
yes the it's there's
long use with them
and safety and dosing
information are available
drug interactions well
anything that
interferes with the
phosphorylation of the
drug So you're not going to
give famciclovir and
valacyclovir together.
And enhanced risk
of renal injury with
other nephrotoxic
drugs or any drugs
that interfere with
renal excretion.
And the one that
just keeps coming
back over and over
would be probenicid.
So that increases
the plasma
concentration. And
as we have heard, the
adverse effects are
dose-related, in
this case,
concentration-related.
Topical products.
It's always
great to be able
to have that
topical option.
So we have some cream
ointment for ******
labialis, a tablet
that can be dissolved.
against the cheek.
Ophthalmic ointment
for ****** keratitis.
Ganciclovir for
****** keratitis.
We have pencyclovir
for ****** labialis.
Cream called docosanol
And this drug that I'm
not going to really
talk about is trifluoridine
ophthalmic drops.
This is something that
I've seen in board
review questions,
this trifluoridane. So
I recommend that when
the time comes, if
you see it in a board
review question, just
look it up. It's pretty
simple to follow.
Again,
very often, except
for the ophthalmics,
the ****** labialis
may need to
be treated with
systemic treatment.
Okay, let's look at
cytomegalovirus
infection now.
Here's this whole
list. Ganciclovir
is the first
in the group.
And we have a
prodrug, the
valine on valgancyclovir.
Here's our ganciclovir.
Here's our
valgancyclovir.
Here's Foscarnet.
This is completely
different. This
is called an
inorganic pyrophosphate
analog. I'll
explain more when
we get there.
Cydofavir.
What I want to point
out is Cydofavir
already has a
phosphate on it.
That's how it's
marketed. marketed.
Lataramivir is a
small molecule, well
certainly bigger than
the other ones, but
this is called a small
molecule inhibitor.
It is not related
to, it's not an
analog of a purine
or a pyrimidine.
And here's maribavir,
which looks
kind of similar,
but it is different.
We'll start
with ganciclovir
and valgancyclovir.
Ganciclovir is now
IV only. It used
to be oral when it
was first marketed.
Valgancyclovir had
not been developed
at the time. It
had really poor
bioavailability. Val-gan
-cyclovir significantly
improves ganciclovir
bioavailability.
And then there's also an
intravitreal
injection, and I talked
about the
ophthalmic already.
So intravitreal, it's
being injected into
the vitreous, the
vitreous humor. Why?
Because CMV retinitis,
retinitis, it's got to
get back to that
retina that's infected.
Class effects, we've
seen it before.
Ah, but look, when
given systemically, it
will distribute to the
intraocular tissues.
really low
protein binding.
So it's nearly all
available for movement
to the various tissues.
Not metabolized,
except, of course,
to the triphosphate.
Unchanged drug
in the urine.
Renal dosing, necessary.
Pretty short half
-life. But intracellular
half-life, also
referred to as
biologic half-life,
is much longer.
And, of course,
with patients with
severe renal impairment,
it's very much
longer, from 4
hours to 68 hours.
Mechanism is
what we saw with,
really, with pencyclovir.
now this is cmv
has a kinase called
ul97 in other words
it's a kinase that's
expressed by this
gene ul97 and that's
what it's called
the ul97 kinase
converts it to
the monophosphate
and then we get
the host kinases
to convert it to
the triphosphate,
which will then
competitively
inhibit DNA polymerase.
Well, what's its
activity? And
the activity
I'm sharing with
you is the in
vitro activity.
We can assume after
all these years
that it also has
in vivo activity on
the various strains
of ******. virus.
But CMV,
100 times greater
activity against CMV
compared to acyclovir.
So I mentioned before
acyclovir is quite
weak against CMV. It's
okay for prophylactic,
but it's not used
for treatment of CMV.
It is useful against
****** simplex virus,
but it's associated
with significantly
more toxicities,
whereas acyclovir,
valacyclovir, and famcyclovir
are very effective
against HSV and
VZV. So why would we
use a more toxic drug?
And it also has
activity against
these others. I'm
not going to be
including that
in this lecture.
Selectivity. Okay.
concentrations are at
least 10 times higher
and cmv infected cells
naturally because
ul97 kinase is there
to convert it it is
a more potent inhibitor
of viral dna polymerase
than host dna
polymerase but it is not
completely selective
it still has some
affinity for the host
dna polymerase Hence,
ganciclovir is more
toxic than acyclovir.
Okay, resistance.
As you would know
by now, resistance
is related to
the drug target. So
in this case, UL97
gene mutations,
that first step.
Any mutations that
prevent conversion to
the monophosphate
is going to prevent
ganciclovir activity
against the virus.
And, again, DNA
polymerase mutations,
which, by the
way, is referred
to, is expressed
by the UL54 gene.
Cross-resistance with
CMV, ganciclovir,
dual mutations in UL97
gene, a potential,
potential cross
-resistance with a drug
we're going to talk
about in a couple.
cytofavir and possibly
foscarnet but foscarnet
might still be
good now with hsv i
mentioned it is effective
against hsv and it
is converted by the
thymidine kinase of
hsv to the monophosphate
so cross resistance
if that thymidine
kinase is deficient
acyclovir pencyclovir
against cyclovir
they're all not useful
what do we use valgan
cycle for valgan cycle
here remember this
is oral it produces
good blood levels and
it would therefore be
preferred whenever
possible it's certainly
much easier for the
patient to manage cmv
retinitis it does
cross into crosses the
ocular barriers the
blood retina barrier
and it is as effective
as intravenous
intravenous gancyclovir
so that's another great
thing we ask ourselves
well I'd rather give
the oral for my
patient but is it going
to be as good? And the
answer here is yes.
Prophylaxis makes
sense for patients who
have received the
stem cell transplant,
hematopoietic stem
cell transplant, or
solid organ transplant
patients, and patients
with AIDS that is
poorly controlled.
now the iv cnv retinitis
treatment chronic
suppression in the
immunocompromised
individual who is not
able to take oral drugs
treatment of
invasive disease
and prophylaxis in
the allogeneic stem
cell or solid organ
transplant recipient
especially when
they're in the hospital
intravitreal injection
well i mentioned
before that by injecting
it straight into
the vitreous humor
we're going to achieve
a high concentration
oh but i also
said valgan cyclovir
also will achieve good
levels within the
vitreous humor so
when do we use the
intravitreal injection
Patients who have the
retinitis, who are
immunocompromised,
our AIDS patients, who
have immediate site
-threatening disease.
And then it's used
in conjunction
with the valacyclovir.
And the varicella zoster
virus retinal necrosis,
and it can be used
together with Foscarnet.
This is, as you
could imagine, just
by looking at it,
it's a terrible thing.
so we want to
really try and bring
the heavy guns
right in there
to at least stop
the progression
ophthalmic gel,
the hepatic
keratitis that was
right into the eye
alright, side
effects I have been
alluding to this
since the beginning
the usual stuff,
diarrhea, nausea
itchy, rash,
headache, insomnia.
Now nephrotoxicity, acute
kidney injury is
the potential.
So we want to
make sure the
patient is
adequately hydrated.
We want to make
sure we're very
careful in
patients who are
receiving
nephrotoxic drugs.
Myelosuppression is the
major dose
-limiting toxicity.
So what does dose
-limiting mean?
It means if we go
above this dose,
we're really
increasing the risk of
myelosuppression, bone
marrow suppression.
And it can be severe.
All of the blood
cells can be affected.
It can occur at any
time during treatment,
and it can worsen
with continued use.
So we follow it. We
have to monitor the
complete blood count
and platelet count.
We have to find
out what they start
with, and we have
to watch it during
therapy to see if
there are changes.
Fertility.
Suppression of
spermatogenesis.
Temporary or permanent.
Suppression of
fertility in females.
Carcinogenic cancer.
Teratogenic
birth defects.
These, as I pointed
out here in this box,
U.S. boxed warnings.
That means be alert.
Moving now to Foscarnet.
Foscarnet is the
pyrophosphate analog.
Here's pyrophosphate.
And here's Foscarnet.
This is a little
molecule, water-soluble.
It causes reversible
non-competitive
block of pyrophosphate
binding site in
viral polymerase.
So this shows
you how we're
building the DNA
along the template.
Here we have our
triphosphate coming in
here, that's the next
step. and it will
attach like this,
like all the rest
of them, and then two
phosphates will go
away. The pyrophosphate
will go away.
So by putting in our
foscar net, let's say
here, it's going to
block that next step.
Usual resistance
concepts.
Activity, a lot of
in vitro activity
has been seen
with this drug.
It inhibits DNA
polymerase, RNA polymerase,
HIV reverse transcriptase,
HIV right here.
Point mutations, cross
resistance, you
can look at that.
Just the same
concepts we've
always been
talking about.
Pharmacokinetics, IV or
intravitreal injection.
It will not be
absorbed taken ******.
It distributes
into the CSF. It
distributes into
the vitreous humor.
It deposits in bone.
It is a phosphate.
Excreted unchanged
in the urine by
glomerular filtration.
This little
molecule dissolved
in the serum.
Half-life. Well,
around three to seven
hours, but it's slowly,
slowly, slowly released
from the body after
the drug is withdrawn
because it's
sequestered in the bone.
So what do we use it for?
Immediate site
-threatening
CMV retinitis treatment.
Often given together
with the ganciclovir.
It can be used
for acyclovir
-resistant HSV and VZV.
pre-emptive
therapy for CMV
prophylaxis in
our stem cell
recipient, transplant
recipients,
treatment of other
CMV tissue invasive
disease, progressive
VZV retinal necrosis
with gencyclovir. It
has some very important
uses for some very
serious infections.
You're going to use
it for a simple ******
simplex infection? No,
we're going to use a
Cyclovir, Valley
Cyclovir, or Famcyclovir.
Nephrotoxicity is
the major toxicity of
this drug. It occurs
to some degree in
the majority of
patients. We don't often
say that. I often
say these are rare
adverse, serious
adverse events that you
have to be looking
for. Well, this is
different. This occurs
in most patients.
So what are we going
to do? Monitor serum
creatinine. We're
talking about the kidney.
Adjust the doses.
Ensure adequate
hydration.
And if you can
avoid it, which you
can't always
because you see it's
used for such
serious infections,
don't give it
to people who
are taking
nephrotoxic drugs.
Seizures.
And this is related
to plasma, mineral,
and electrolyte
imbalance because of its
phosphate incidence
is up to 10% in AIDS
patients. That's a pretty
significant number.
Speaking of mineral
and electrolyte
imbalances, this
phosphate will
chelate magnesium
and calcium.
and it can
also cause some
hypokalemia and
it can cause low
phosphate or
high phosphate.
So what are we going
to do? We're going
to monitor, monitor,
monitor, monitor.
Also, just because,
nausea, vomiting, anemia,
liver enzymes, headache,
hallucinations, fatigue.
I don't know if it's safe
in pregnancy
or lactation.
Moving now to
Cidofovir. This is an
acyclic citadine
analog now, and as I
mentioned before, it
has a phosphate on it.
IV only this is a must
saline prehydration with
probenicid and
I'll get to that
doesn't get very high
concentrations within
the cerebral spinal
fluid urine on chains
seeing that all the
way through aren't we
intracellular half
-life much longer than
the plasma half-life
can do one-time weekly
dosing maintenance
dosing every two weeks
intracellular
phosphorylation by the host
so it's already got
that one phosphate
on it you can consider
it a monophosphate
and then it gets two
more phosphates by
host kinases so So,
that's called cytofavir
diphosphate because
two phosphates
are being added to
the original molecule,
even though there are
three phosphates on it.
Potent inhibition of
viral DNA polymerase
by competitive inhibition
of deoxycytidine
triphosphate. So,
that's the natural
nucleotide that's being
blocked from joining.
Incorporation
of the viral DNA
chain slows
and eventually
terminates the
chain elongation.
What do we use it for?
CMV retinitis and
tissue invasive disease.
Tissue invasive CMV.
Preemptive therapy in
stem cell recipients.
Stem cell transplant
recipients.
And it's got a number
of non-CMV uses.
And I want to point
out M-Pox, but it
has to be used
together with this drug
that's specifically
for M-Pox. I'm not
getting into that
particular virus. It's an
orthopox virus. It
doesn't have anything
to do with our
****** viridae group.
Oh boy, here we go again.
Nephrotoxicity, the
major toxicity. I'll
talk more about that
on the next slide.
Reduced neutrophil
count, potential
for cancer,
potential for birth
defects, suppression
of fertility,
ocular complications.
It can cause uveitis
or iritis or permanent
vision impairment.
What do we not use it
with? other nephrotoxic
agents, not only
right now being
administered concurrently,
but also within
seven days from the time
they were discontinued.
We do not put it
directly into the
eye. We do not inject
it into the vitreous
humor. We do not
give it in pregnancy.
Drug interactions, of
course, nephrotoxicity,
and I'm going to
talk about that one.
Okay, let's talk
about nephrotoxicity.
Cytofovir can
cause proximal
tubular dysfunction,
the chief dose
-limiting side effect.
and how do we
recognize it well the
protein gets spilled
into the urine nitrogen
accumulates in the
our nitrogenous
products accumulate
in the blood glucose
spills over into the
urine patient can
develop metabolic
acidosis and this renal
tubular acidosis of
Fanconi syndrome.
So, okay, how do
we mitigate this?
Well, we have all this
drug going into the
renal tubules. So, we
would like to reduce
the concentration of
the drug going into
the renal tubules at
any given moment. So,
how do we do that?
Well, we can hydrate.
We put plenty of fluid
going into the tubules
at the same time.
And we can block the
organic anion transporter
with probenicid. So
that is going to slow
the secretion of the
cydofavir into the tubule.
So between increasing
the hydration, so
diluting the drug
that's in the tubule,
and slowing the secretion
of the drug into the
tubule, that will at
least reduce the
concentration of drug in the
tubule, and that
can mitigate this
nephrotoxicity
effect. Which is not
to say that it's
not going to happen,
it can still happen.
So, what is the
worst? Cases of acute
renal failure resulting
in dialysis or
contributing to death
have occurred in as
few as one or two
doses of Cidofovir.
How important is this
for you to remember?
Extremely important.
It is pharmacology
principles plus
safety of the patient.
Is it tested
on the boards?
I really don't know.
But you need to know it.
Moving now to
lutermivir. This is
something called a CMV
DNA terminase complex
inhibitor. it inhibits
the maturation
packaging and
termination process
and therefore it
prevents replication
oral it's also an
iv here's another
pharmacology concept
the iv the litermivir
is not very soluble
in IV solution, so
it's mixed up together
with this stuff
called hydroxypropyl
betadex vehicle.
And that will solubilize
the latermavir
into the IV
solution so it can
be administered
through the vein.
The hydroxypropyl betadex
vehicle is associated
with its own potential
adverse effects.
So that's why as
soon as the patient
can take an oral
drug, it should
be switched over
to the oral.
Monitor creatinine
clearance.
Highly plasma
protein bound.
First time
we've seen this.
Substrative transporters.
These are hepatic
transporters. It's
called organic anion
transport peptide,
1B1 and 1B3. So
that P on there is
telling you it's a
hepatic transporter.
And our old friend,
P-glycoprotein.
Bioavailability,
not great.
Okay, but enough.
They figured it out.
They figured dosing
out so that 35%
bioavailability are still
going to get adequate
systemic concentrations,
but I want
to point out this
cyclosporine and
I want to point
out this and this.
Cyclosporine inhibits
these and when
that happens, the
concentrations can
more than double
as a result
of this drug interaction.
OATP also.
All three.
Fortunately there are
dosing recommendations.
So who gets
cyclosporine? I
never heard of
this drug, right?
Cyclosporine is solid
organ transplant
patients.
And what do we worry
about with solid
organ transplant patients?
that they're going
to get an organ
that's got CMV in it.
So cyclosporine is
important for this,
and latermavir is
important for this.
So we have to
absolutely remember
that potential
drug interaction,
look at the literature,
and see what the
suggestions are for
adjusting the dose
of the latermavir.
It goes out through
the feces, 70%
unchanged, but it
also has a really low
bioavailability,
poor absorption
actually, as well as
first pass effect.
Decent half-life though.
So mechanism.
Here we have the
genome of the HSV,
the CMV I should
say, CMV. And this is
called a reading
frame, reading frame,
that's a terminology
that's used.
Litermivir
binds something
called protein UL56.
So UL56 expresses
this protein, a
particular protein
in the terminase
complex, and so
it's named PUL56.
By binding to
PUL56, it blocks the
CMV DNA terminase
complex, and the
complex, which is
indicated right
here, is made up
of these proteins.
So by inhibiting
this one, it inhibits
the terminase complex
activity, which will
then Then it
inhibits all of this
downstream activity,
maturation, packaging,
and it will stop
the process,
alters the genome length,
and vary in maturation.
So resistance,
where's the
resistance going to be?
Of course, UL56,
point mutations,
and isolates
have been reported
during therapy.
So that's basically
it. Here's our UL
-97, remember we talked
about that kinase.
And UL-54, I've
indicated which one that
is on the next slide,
or on a later slide.
What do we use
Litaramavir for?
Prophylaxis of
CMV infection,
prophylaxis of
disease in adult CMV
seropositive recipients
of allogeneic
hematopoietic stem
cell transplant.
So people who are
receiving stem cell
transplants who are
CMV seropositive,
the lintermavir
would be given to
prevent the full
-blown CMV infection.
Highly active,
highly specific,
highly active
against CMV,
including drug-resistant
isolates. So those
isolates are resistant
because of UL-97
changes or some other
reason, but not UL-56.
It has no activity
against other
viruses, Just CMV, and
it's only indicated
currently for the
prophylaxis of
CMV in this particular
patient group.
CMV seropositive
recipients of allogeneic
hematopoietic stem
cell transplant.
Nausea, vomiting,
diarrhea, abdominal pain.
It seems like this
happens with practically
all drugs, doesn't
it? Doesn't mean
everybody will suffer
it, but some will.
Headache, fatigue,
peripheral edema,
tachycardia, decreased
platelet counts, decreased
hemoglobin. What
are we going to do?
Monitor.
High risk of serious
adverse events,
especially
related to CYP3A4
inhibition. We talked
about cyclosporine.
Tacrolimus is another
drug. Both of these
drugs are not used
together, but they're
both used for
the same purpose.
immunosuppressant in solid
organ transplantation.
Sirolimus is
another CYP3A4 drug
that's used in
transplantation therapy.
All of these drugs
can have very
serious adverse
effects, potential
for severe life
-threatening toxicities
related to CYP3A4
inhibition.
Many more metabolism
transport, so you
could know this already
just by seeing the
pharmacokinetics.
Distribution, metabolism,
clinically relevant
pharmacokinetic
properties.
And our final drug,
meribivir. Now, this
is a protein UL97
inhibitor. Remember UL97?
It's a kinase.
Remember that?
Oral, high prasmoprotein
binding again.
CYP3A4 is back.
Urine feces is
inactive metabolites.
Pretty simple,
straightforward
pharmacokinetic. It is
a competitive inhibitor
of this UL97 protein,
the CMV kinase.
Prevents a
phosphorylation step.
Inhibits CMV DNA
replication. In
other words, it
inhibits all that
downstream stuff
by blocking this
initial kinase to
the monophosphate.
substitutions in
the ul-97 gene
we already talked
about that with
ganciclovir and
valgancyclovir
post-transplant cmv
infection not responsive
to the available
anti-cmv drugs in
adults and children
who are 12 years old
and older and you
will see when you
look at the literature
they also talk about
the weight of the
individual patient.
Diarrhea, nausea,
vomiting, decreased
hemoglobin platelets,
fatigue, taste
disorder, blah, blah,
blah. All the same
things. So get those
class effects in
mind. And all you have
to remember is the
drugs that have some
unique features.
Pregnancy, not
tested in pregnant
humans, so better
not to give it.
Avoid strong
CYP3A4 inducers and
inhibitors. Do not
combine with ganciclovir
due to diminished
efficacy of ganciclovir.
Why? It's inhibiting
UL-97, which
is required to
convert gancyclovir.
Make sense?
And I've given
you some of
the summary tables here.
And more summaries.
Hopefully this will
help you. I recommend
that you make
your own tables or
charts or however
you can put the
information together.
And I'm sure you can
do it all on one page.
And a summary,
which I won't read
to you, it's easy
for you to get.
And here are
the references.
And that concludes
the antiviral
therapy related to
the ****** viridae.